[Music]
welcome back everyone its charlie big
surprise they dropped a brand new Rick
and Morty season 4 opening scene so
we'll break it down there's a whole
bunch of Easter eggs and guess which of
the scenes are real and which are
actually scenes from episodes we're
doing a new round of that Rick and Morty
merch giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave all
your theories about which of these
scenes are real and which are fake on
the video even if you're brand new to
Rick and Morty and you haven't been
watching for a long time you probably
noticed that the order of fake and real
scenes has switched just a little bit
between season 1 season 2 in season 3 so
far so between season 1 season 2 in
season 3 they sort of switched up the
order which are real in which are fake
they used to alternate with a very
specific order for the first couple of
seasons that they switched up for season
3 no matter to the season they always
start with the season 1 scenes of them
opening with the equations and the
planets transitioning to Rick escaping
the monsters and leaving Morty behind
everybody grab your vouchers for one
free replacement Morty but then you have
the new scene of Rick using a breathing
mask to fly through the vacuum of space
without a spacesuit into what looks like
a giant chaotic space battle raging
between different factions while a
massive Cronenberg looking morty
destroys all the ships that get too
close to him he spins around looking
really pissed off then there's another
new scene of Rick Morty and Beth in the
garage next to Rick's spaceship
surrounded by angry looking cyborg
Terminator snakes that look like they
want to kill them until they're rescued
by a different Terminator looking cyborg
snake that's walking on to cyborgs legs
fighting all the other snakes off then
turning around to address them and
explain itself the reason why I think
this is another Terminator cyborg snake
is because its head is the exact same
shape as the heads of all these snakes
it's just that it has cyborg legs that
is walking around on then there's a new
scene of Morty hooked up to an IV drip
and what kind of seems like Rick's
bedroom falling asleep on his cot then
he crashes into some psychic barrier
into another reality where Rick is in
the middle of getting the crap beat out
of him by some evil looking shirtless
scientist in what kind of seems like a
Flash Gordon
esque science fiction adventure serial
parody he's got a bunch of shiny rings
with different colored gems on his
gloved hands which is giving me Avengers
infinity war an end
Infinity Gauntlet flashbacks love the
look of terror on Morty's face here then
there's another new scene of Morty
either made giant terrorizing aliens at
their beach or is regular-sized Morty
terrorizing a bunch of tiny aliens at
their beach this kind of seems like it's
a parody of the release the Kraken scene
from the classic Clash of the Titans
movie then there's another new scene of
Rick Morty Beth and summer all in the
kitchen running from a two-headed goose
that's chasing them revealing that Rick
has modified the refrigerator to be a
backup weapons storage locker he grabs
one of the weapons and gets ready to
shoot the goose they've shown in many
different episodes but primarily in
season 3 episode 6 when he's fighting
toxic Rick that he has weapons hidden
all over the house not just in the
garage where his workshop is then they
always end with that same scene from
previous seasons of them flying away
from Cthulhu who's trying to destroy
them for stealing baby Cthulhu still
waiting on that Cthulhu episode that
they keep joking that they'll do
eventually so if you watch some of the
previous trailer videos that I've done
you've noticed some familiar footage in
this so we already know for sure that at
least one of these scenes is real but a
good clue is following the pattern from
season 1 season 2 and how they changed
that pattern to season 3 opening scene
the season 1 opening scene pattern was
in just basic alternating fake and real
scenes so it started with the fake scene
of Morty falling and not making it
through the portal the real scene of
Jerry versus the bugs with the shotgun
that was from Rick potion number 9
there's the fake scene of Jerry finding
out about robot Morty then the real
scene of Rick struggling fighting the
family with that Nintendo cartridge
that's from the opening of meeseeks and
destroy' there's the fake scene of
pregnant Jerry the real scene of them
being saved in anatomy Park and then the
fake scene of Rick Morty and summer
escaping giant Cthulhu so there's just
basically fake real fake real fake real
season 2 was a similar pattern you start
with the fake scene of rick drilling
into the dining room being chased by the
mole people
then the real scene of rick's stunning
Morty during look who's purging now in
their Iron Man suits the fake scene of
Rick trying to figure
a science problem while Jerry almost
gets killed the real scene of Rick and
summer pillow fighting with mr.
Beauregard from Total Recall then the
fake scene of all the different Rick's
working together they changed the
pattern of fake and real just a little
bit during season three's opening scene
though it starts with a scene on a world
where everyone's faces are butts with
butt face Morty getting caught looking
at rub hub then instead of alternating
to a real scene it's another fake scene
of two different summers working
together to infiltrate the Galactic
government facility with Rick then it
alternates to two real scenes the
Morty's escaping during tales from the
Citadel during their standby me parody
then the real scene of Rick and Morty
almost getting killed by piano man
concerto here being saved by Jaguar at
the end of pickle Rick and the end
credits scene then it alternates back to
fake with Rick shopping for a
replacement Morty at the mortise store
so which is alternating to fake scenes
to to real scenes back to fake so taking
those changes into account early
prediction for season four opening scene
order is the space battle with
Cronenberg Morty is fake the Terminator
space snakes scene is real because we
saw a totally different Terminator
parody seen in the last trailer with
those snakes a lot different from season
three we've got a lot of a lot of
shoot-'em-ups a lot of laser shoot
amongst the scene of Morty falling into
the dream world might be fake the scene
of Morty going all cracking Morty might
be fake making the scene of Rick vs. the
two-headed goose reel so everybody leave
your predictions about which of these
scenes are in season four episodes and
which are fake but for those of you
hoping for that Cthulhu episode there's
actually a clip of Justin a couple years
ago explaining what their plan is that
they're all meant to be technically real
scenes but they just won't get to those
episodes to way way later on
[Music]
the credits are real things that are
gonna happen in future episodes you
ready here first
it might take til when Justin's son is
doing the voices but we'll get to so at
some point it sounds like they're
planning on paying that off and because
they have the 70 episode order it's a
lot easier for them to slot those things
in if you look at the giant box here
this is them closing down their season
for writers room transitioning to season
five stuff the picture there be story
generator just shows you how many crazy
ideas they come up with but because
season four episode one is premiering
Sunday night my full video for episode 1
is gonna post Monday mornings so as long
as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you should see that when I
posted it makes us run faster jump
higher okay let's eat the baby I know
everybody wants to know what's going on
with Evel Morty I've already had a
chance to see episode 1 so I did a
non-spoilery review of that I'll add a
link to that at the end of this the
season is as good as ever and a lot of
people were worried what was gonna
happen to their creative flow between
the giant break and them trying to get
that 70 episode renewal but for those of
you that are worried that they're gonna
end the show after those 70 episodes are
done the way they talk about it they're
optimistic that they'll go way beyond
that but I don't think that it's
realistic to expect them to go as long
as something like The Simpsons or South
Park as much as people would love to see
something like that it's just really
really hard to keep creative levels up
for longer than say like 15 or 16
seasons right now the 70 episode order
gets them to ten seasons assuming they
do 10 episodes per season well let me
know in the comments how many total
seasons do you think Rick and Morty will
go do you think they'll go beyond 10
will they make it past 12 or 15 I'll
name a new giveaway winner when I post
my next Rick and Morty video everyone
click here for my early non-spoilery
review of Rick and Morty season 4
episode 1 and click here for that last
really big Rick and Morty season 4
trailer video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]